[música]
la mayor parte de incluso aquellos que tenían otros
puntos de vista
se han movilizado y
ya quieren ser protegidos para que ellos
permanecieron vivos y en sus hogares y entienden
qué
tenemos un sistema diferente y, en general, la vida
el otro que estan detras de la cortina de hierro no es
ellos quieren
[música]
Le dije a mi pariente en Rusia el mío
cuando llego mi espiritu quien vino estoy listo
dientes manos mi marido exactamente igual mia
niños igual
dijeron que yo estaba en el segundo mundo
dijeron que no cederemos ni una pulgada de tierra con seguridad
también mi casa y todo lo que tengo
rodeado de un amigo preguntó
pues que tal jyj mas si vienen bien
como si tuvieras que agacharte aquí, pero en tu
Rodeado de alguien se alegra de que ella ha venido
Rusia en nuestro territorio respondiste
no los hay en mi entorno, y aunque lo sean
hay algo conmigo que no se atreven y melancolía
la moral solo se fortalece 5
[música]